[Music]  yeah what is Chi Chi excuse me some cool  crime-fighting dog this this virus is  killing people and soon it'll be too  late to stop it for a secret division of  the CDC we hunt down two things diseases  and criminals who is behind this we want  answers what kind of God would make a  virus like that God's not the bad guy  here  wait back bioterrorism what's this look  like to you I switch brain even better  whoa  it's a cult whoa we have many enemies  some of them we know some of them we  don't it is time for you to stop playing  pretend cops and get back to your  hospital that is in order to move we got  to be careful not to wake  [Music]  great job this is crazy we're in way  over our heads  oh and we can't do this what happened  this in Berlin Sudan we need  weapons-grade plutonium Fernet arc  attack  hi we are the police and we're doctors  which makes us cop doctors oh I was  gonna say doctor cops I like that better  three two one total badass  you  you